we send the uncut version of this movie
by accident and yes I'm giving the movie
a sin for this because ultimately I
watched about 20 more minutes of this
tripe than I should have had to Comcast
oh great dreams position explaining
Christian's toughness maybe we should
give this guy 45 more chances like
Anastasia does you mean is in the
director of Glengarry Glen Ross James
Foley and you mean is in the director
who's that girl's James Foley
reanimating Madonna's corpse for a video
full of xylophone music would be better
than this this movie exists I know let's
get a cover of Coldplay's the scientist
but this time we'll make it slow and
mournful oh wait listen asshole there is
such a thing as planting right or
getting this bouquet to a cancer kid
still not sure what kind of pictures
this franchise has of Danny Elfman to
continue forcing him to score these
shirts who are these people am I
supposed to remember I'll be honest I
watched the first movie I wrote since
for the first movie still not sure I
remember any of it
I'm sorry Dakota Johnson is gorgeous who
decided to style her with these bangs
and two red lipstick for this movie Maga
- she's on the bus and the last movie he
gave her a car I guess we're jumping
ahead and they've broken up and she's
refusing his money and cars and thus
rides the bus now but the bus the boss
researching researching this dude is he
L James husband this means to me is that
nobody in Hollywood wanted to write this
putting thing not even Anne Rice I mean
look at this fucking apartment
how can she afford to live here in this
place which in Seattle is probably three
thousand dollars a month or more but has
to take the goddamn bus home from work
moving in to make up its mind about how
much money she has my boss has me
weighing in on submissions I thought it
was your former boyfriend Christian Grey
who was having you weigh in on
submissions the hell kind of
photographer invites a person to an
exhibit but does not tell that person
they are featured in said exhibit an
immoral one that's it
like so much of my face in here if I had
asked you would have been like I'm too
shy also sounds like another way of
saying no but let's go with the I'm too
shy bit to soften it they just bought
all six if only he'd known there was an
untapped Christian Grey market out there
he could have made the whole exhibit
Anastasia Steele and retired just talk
please have dinner with me yeah I just
went from just talk someplace private to
dinner wicked fast
Jose watches her leave with Christian
and looks on disapprovingly because he
is the Jacob in this movie which means
he hates Christian loves Ana and will
eventually fall in love with her
daughter roughly a few months after
she's born Christian leads Ana into
murder
Alley which is bad enough but then he
starts to kissing her with no warning
which seems kind of wrong but she kisses
him back this movie spent its first nine
minutes pouring on the evidence that she
hated him but 10 minutes after their
first reunion they're both down to whose
hornier these characters at the people
writing them two-stage medium fries
cream vegetables Wow okay first
scientist for ordering for your female
date like you're in the 1950s I don't
care that she shows power by correcting
him and ordering a quinoa salad mmm sin
for his ordering still stands second sin
is for simply saying cream vegetables as
part of your order that could mean
anything from creamed spinach to boiled
cabbage to canned peas I know you're
more worried about talking to Anna than
the meal itself as is the movie but god
damn dude order like you've eaten a meal
before Jesus I'll have the meat to
vegetables in a carb of some kind things
you said that's the way you are I mean
cinemasins did a whole bonus round on
that no rules
how does this ever get fifty shades
darker without any punishments and no
more secrets she seems more concerned
moving forward that he won't keep
secrets from her than she is that he
might viciously spank her ass with a
whip again I see along with her bangs
anna has also recently trimmed her
perspective reattached look if you're
just gonna start naming movies that are
way better than this one we're gonna be
here a long time
this is yeah just wait until it's
shaping your inner thigh what was wrong
I just mean boss saves his secretary
from creepy sidewalk chick by taking her
off for a beer just the two of them is
the greater sin the boss is timing or
his intentions Christian this is Jade
I'm the boyfriend Jesus I humbly submit
that any guy who introduces himself to
his girl's boss this way is an asshole
and trust me I know assholes
wait that came out wrong can't believe
you just talked to him like that he
wants what's mine
yours just one day after this asshole
gets Anastasia back he's already talking
about her an extremely possessive terms
and this movie is allowed to continue
yeah you new favorite flavor
god damn it now I'll never be able to
use vanilla ice cream during a sex act
again without getting grossed out
never dick rush a guy who is actively
chopping vegetables with a sharp knife
do you want severed fingers because this
is how you get severed fingers no that's
dude she already brushed your dick and
insinuated you guys were about to be
sleeping with each other suddenly the
chest is off-limits maybe I should have
paid attention to the nightmare at the
beginning but I think you and I can
agree this movie was asking too much
this is her bedroom okay first of all if
Kevin Costner kills them tonight he will
get photographed by someone across the
way taking photos
second of all someone is surely across
the way taking photos yes I'm sure that
sounded sexy and the screenwriters head
but he never bothered to say it out loud
also movie we're only watching for the
sex takes over 21 minutes to sex
you already asked us in the kitchen two
minutes ago and she replied you so why
are you asking it again pants on pink so
was that figure in the bedroom just for
us was a foreshadowing was it a dream
you movie just focus on the sex and
leave whore to blum house could you
please transfer $24,000 into the calamus
Anastasia Steele this is the second time
in eight minutes where the movie is
allowed to continue after Christian Grey
does something like this
holy hell you could fit an entire clown
cars worth of clowns under that big-ass
umbrella you know that girl I'm handling
it what does that mean I want you to
worry about it
trust him haha
discount Kim basically Sh
why would you take me to meet the woman
who seduced and abused you I'm pretty
sure if I went to see this movie in
theaters I would have been kicked out by
now
first off I'd be unable to keep up sin
ADIZ to a minimum second off my hands
would constantly be thrown up in the air
wondering why Anastasia puts up with
this third off I woulda peed on a Logan
display out no Bobby I don't care what
your name is Christian why would you
take me there she has a good point the
goodest of points this is king Seattle
and there are likely three dozen
overpriced spas for rich dudes to pay
for the girlfriends to get better
haircuts our relationship ended years
ago we're just friends
classic not answering the question Leela
whoops the fact that I have a whole file
on her with her social security number
sexual orientation and that she has a
mother named yoohoo Bronco should not
scare you whatsoever
seriously Christian has files on the
women he Fox he takes surveillance
photos she'll continue to fuck him after
this this should have been called Fifty
Shades Dumber am i right I had them
drawn up and any perspectives of miss
doesn't make a less creepy dude
seriously this mother should be in jail
he's a stalker predator abuser and
probably more we don't even see like an
insider trader this isn't a relationship
Christian its ownership she's 100% right
and yet the rest of this movie and at
least one more movie will still continue
come on I better honest sex is not gonna
fix this right now are you insane denna
please and that's all it takes to get
her to agree she was literally just
justifiably lambaste in him for his
multiple sub spying etc but he says
please and she just relents ladies of
the world there are men out there lots
of them that do not treat women like
this and are happy to just give you a
roof and some cuddles when she's done
it's gonna be an upside down portrait of
Abraham Lincoln what does this do for
her the argument was about Christian
doing fucked up like giving her money
she doesn't want and buying the company
he works for and taking her to the salon
where Kim Basinger works had nothing to
do with no touch zones but now she's on
board with being with him after this Bob
Ross lipstick scene yeah
who's here okay god damn it you can play
head games all you want Christian but
when you play the pronoun game you've
gone too far
job her name is an estate Oh three
minutes of the movie or dedicated to
Benoit balls no this is exactly what my
college ex-girlfriend said when I showed
her my collection of Transformers toys
Brandon why me if chosen a poor time to
do so bad guys always travel in a convoy
of black s you'd wait purpose was a sex
movie why are there bad guy SUVs
literally no one we've seen so far is
looking at you you got exposed from four
different schools for Brawley
that's nothing he's been expelled from
14 nonprofit boards for bending people
over and spanking them suddenly random
properties the highly wealthy Christian
owns is a big deal to Anastasia when all
the other terribleness should have had
her running since Rio one movie is
modern and takes place in roughly 2016
2017 but here's the television set from
1998 just for kicks
look I'm down with a good sexual
spanking like anyone else but why does
this matter this is why these kinds of
movies don't make good sequels the shock
of it all was spent on the first one and
what's worse her concerns about this guy
are completely gone I can't write this
as a sin and Chris will and should
delete it but goddamn does she have a
great ass the character I mean aren't
you supposed to create a safe word I
nominate the word Twilight
this goes on for some time Christian
doesn't even take off his pants and I
get that urgency for sex does happen and
sex with pants on does happen but
regardless the scene is being played as
passionate when really Anna's poor
thighs are being utterly chafed right
now by some combination of belt parts
zipper parts and cotton polyester blend
cloth maybe I've just out of myself as a
sex should be done mostly naked
proponent but it's a platform I'm
willing to base my entire political
campaign around meanwhile back at the
ball we don't give a shit about in the
first place they move it decides to show
us that the ball is still going on well
isn't that neat fake photo of young
Christian Grey is so fake that I'm
surprised Anastasia doesn't confront
Christian about it again when he doesn't
give her an answer she's so near and
dear to his heart she wedges her picture
into a USC poster frame do you think
you're the first woman he'd hoped would
save him lady you literally just said
without me he'd be in jail or dead so it
wasn't he saved I swear to God and I
don't mean this as an insult but whoever
wrote this has never interacted with a
human being before it's like someone
asked an AI bought to rip off Twilight
and BOTS being BOTS we ended up with
conversations that make no sense like
this one
he needs a submissive in life not just
in the better no he's changing that
Anastasia believes this ok a few things
here first you have a car why were you
riding the bus earlier
second they clearly established that
they were going to Christians place but
her car is there
why and the limo she said T in my house
and he instead decided to take her to
his place so her car was there already
and she wanted to be dropped off at home
by the SUVs even with her car at
Christians is that why she takes the bus
yes the Vandals snuck past security to
wreck Anna's car
Christian's penthouse so we can't stay
there tonight but surely she has no idea
he has a boat right this boat on a
public dock is way more secure if
something were to happen to you because
of me hey psycho bitch just vandalized
Anastasia's car man she's perfectly calm
and confident that nothing is going to
happen to her should have called this
movie Fifty Shades dumber oh wait okay
minor props to the movie for still
having that lipstick on his torso but
also no one will be seated during the
anesthesia sponges Christian's chest
lipstick off scene Christian does not
open up and tell her those things but
they nonetheless Stay Puft look I
understand why the first book and movie
were such big hits sex man
dirty fantasy sex but what is completely
unclear is how the sequel managed to
rope anyone in zero sex the stakes are
not raised this is just some boring
Nicholas Sparks type movie now this
movie would have you believe that Ana
never goes a single moment without her
two bright red lipstick handy she just
woke up his lipstick literally the first
move for her I mean I go to the bathroom
and brush my teeth take a shower
whether morning or just after a nap this
girl goes lipstick first then all other
concerns
[Music]
we now interrupt this movie to sell the
soundtrack to this movie also when I
think of a book and a movie Empire based
on BDSM I think of Taylor Swift in a
heartbeat you're going in circles is
what you're doing worse than that you're
backtracking then going in circles since
we already previously saw this shot
where you were past the unique island
with the clear brown rocky patch and
headed to the bay or maybe just maybe
the overhead crew shot a ton of b-roll
and then little attention was paid
during editing regardless can we just
agree these are some lazy ass movies
okay so does Christian always send this
dream of me text or is this the first
one because remember earlier in the
movie he said I heard this bullshit and
she sent back a completely different
text than the one that appears here do
we care one way or another what
Christian thinks about Anastasia going
to New York with a boss do we care what
happens if she decides to go against his
wishes maybe there are people who hope
they don't break up but those people are
sick bastards and shouldn't be
approached in public also I hate to
bring this up but when she replies I
wasn't asking it shows that she
punctuated it with a period when it goes
back to her phone she didn't punctuate
at all so now you can all feel free to
hate this movie because I know you were
holding back before now stay wasn't
Christian's place deemed not safe
because that car vandalism and stalker
no one has caught yet and that's why
they slept on the boat which they then
took out for leisure after why is this
place suddenly saving it the fatal
stalker hasn't been caught why leave
that night but come back a day later
you're either worried about security or
you're not if you had a room like this
in your home would you ever forget to
lock it I don't think you would
those are nipple clamps I feel like she
should know this already and now I think
the movie is just getting off on showing
us sex equipment which is a truly ironic
fetish learn to walk before we run
I kind of like running what no you don't
that's the whole point of these movies
we've seen so far last time we did this
you saw another side of me and you left
no it wasn't holy Sh what is this and by
the way wasn't she pissed about him
putting his foot down about New York
what happened to that Oh
cops Wow this franchise was supposed to
be about the edge of BDSM stuff but here
in the exact middle of the trilogy
halfway through the second movie we're
doing cuffs that's it is this the darker
they're talking about
hey somebody wake me up when the darker
happens still got an hour to prove the
title isn't a lie I'm so grateful for
the opportunity jack but I said short
notice I made plans that I can't change
eight a minute didn't she and Christian
agree to go to New York together in the
previous scene just three minutes ago
isn't she still going is this movie now
saying she's not doming fucking fuck
well if you're gonna care way to
prominence that you should do it with
someone who can at least make you
smarter what the actual plenty of rich
people penthouses have been filmed but
this might be the most couch infested
and heavily pilote penthouse apartment
in the history of film
I tried counting chairs and pillows and
woke up seven hours later speaking
Portuguese before we run Jesus Christ
like you care
you're the one who's constantly breaking
your principles voice Fox for example
got 80,000 hits last week oh man since
here
first of all 80,000 hits hits me even
talking about person who made up
internet hits as a positive marketing
statistic
second of all 80,000 newsflash you dick
eighty thousand anything on the internet
means exactly nothing while she enjoys
the fact that she just got promoted to
her former boss's job I'd like to remind
everyone mostly her that this is a
company that is essentially owned by her
kinky sex partner boyfriend so Vaska you
want an ax but earned or unearned is
something everyone from your co-workers
to movie viewers will be discussing for
a long time this celebration home you
know for another unexcited sexy this
movie is like porn but we're not the
pizza delivery guy and the hole in the
box Elif angering also is this the best
they can do man I'd rather watch fear
wear Marky Mark does this to Reese
Witherspoon on a roller coaster at least
there's a real ride there
he's clearly fingering her here and I
just like to speak for humanity when I
say you cannot finger a lady on an
elevator without someone else realizing
it through at least one of their five
senses I mean sex smells also what's it
like to be an extra in this scene I got
to be in a movie once fifty shades
darker that was one of those people on
the elevator when Christian fingers
Anastasia anyway mom send more money
[Music]
Jesus they literally just cut from a
scene of them exiting an elevator after
he fingered her then immediately cut to
another shot of them getting off another
elevator
dear rich people combining the poolroom
and the library and the wine cellar
genius I tell you this movie gets super
crazy when Tom Cruise shows up and
starts training Anastasia to be a real
pool shark and then they grand moff
tarkin Paul Newman into this thing hey
remember that chick who had the bandage
around her arm we thought was real
important and there was drama about
Anastasia's car getting vandalized yeah
I don't either then playing pool and her
being better than expected at pool is
maybe the stupidest waste of time in the
entire film and then he bends her over
and does her doggy style came here to
see the craziest sex ever and you got
that terrible sex scene between Meryl
Streep and Liam Neeson and before and
after you gotta love these kind of
movies where random people have the
ability to just break into whatever
place they want with no sign of forced
entry also didn't Christian have his men
looking out for this chick or did they
forget her like the movie did you should
have had a security system installed in
her apartment the day after her car was
vandalized that way no one would be able
to break in and give you reason to feel
like you should go up there with her now
you'd think someone outside like
Christian or his men would've heard that
gunshot master sleeps in your bed how do
you know that I saw you remember how you
left the curtains open told you someone
was watching hail Kim Basinger was
probably out there watching as well yeah
am I wrong or did they just turn this
character into a submissive MacGuffin
like she's really not important to the
plot or anything just a tool so that
Anna will start believing she can't give
Christian what he really wants and
something called a fifty Shades free can
be made sad dumpster walk say boss how
many shots are walking in the rain do
you think we needed to truly convey her
current emotional state
oh man at least 16 now we know why it
rains so much in Seattle it's usually
because Christian and Anastasia are
fighting I'm scared
not because of the controlling nature
and all the red flags but because I
might not be submissive enough they
nearly broke up yesterday and she just
woke him up from a terrible nightmare
three seconds ago and he rolls over and
says this Christian Grey has a pommel
horse at his home gym and he's about to
use it as part of his daily workout
regimen this is impressive but god damn
there's still 30 minutes left in this
movie and all the conflicts are resolved
oh no Mary oh why because divorce is
common these days and not so much of a
stigma and I'll be having you sign a
prenup anyway so basically it's not that
much of a risk or leap pretty sure this
character has already been on-screen in
this movie and yet no conclude this is
might still be the movies fault
remember that close friend of Anna's who
was a photographer
the beginning of the film you hasn't
shown up since then so Seattle pop-up
mobile Street bodega actually has gift
boxes my ass I can't open it till the
day though the wall I give it to me now
call it delay in gratification or in the
case of this movie no gratification hey
did you guys know Seattle has a Space
Needle building cuz this movie seems
determined to make sure you do if you
didn't before
dull movie calls Portland dull and I'm
ready to give this movie 50 sins out of
spite hell Portland Tennessee is less
dull in this movie they're proud and
progressive I hear pressuring a girl on
a marriage proposal response is
generally not considered kosher it's
also not wise given what limited
knowledge I have attained about women
over the years also do you really want
to get engaged over text messages
because this is how you can gauged over
text messages screenwriters fantasy
about dying in a helicopter crash while
writing this bullshit accidentally makes
it into the script and gets filmed is
the main climactic problem seriously
going to be Christian nearly dying in a
helicopter crash like seriously so for
the sequel you ripped off 90 percent
Twilight and 10 percent San Andreas I'd
get good money if once they crash they
get devoured by vampires and werewolves
because they accidentally literally
crashed into a Twilight movie it was
incredible hey that guy the photographer
guy from the opening movie forgot about
him for nearly two hours but there is
still being that guy and stuff and his
colleague Rose Bailey have been found
safe and well who that was such a
horrifying three minutes that they
dedicated to this helicopter crash for a
minute there I thought it was gonna be
something impactful to the story god I'm
glad everyone's okay also here's another
thousand sins I'm a photographer you
know I mean I realize it's late and
we're all jazzed Christian survived that
deadly crash and I love Anna and will
never get to be with her but I totally
have valid reasons for taking off early
here movie goes through a Return of the
King length farewell and it's only the
second goddamn movie
Jesus this movie makes the word yes seem
like it's two hours long this is me
that's just dude if it's on a keychain
it's for life fully clothed the shower
for plague all that earlier about his
need to dominate at the end she just
relents and says this honestly might be
the two movie franchise leads I hate
most in all of cinema they both deserve
to be miserable and die alone sorry but
it's true these people all suck why yes
there are 15 minutes left in this movie
thanks for asking how are you are you
guys good he's the one he sure is
he's the only person who can bring down
the matrix and give me that sweet sweet
rage against the
credits music have you called ray no not
yet
Christian did though he asked for his
permission Christian gray ask anesthesia
dad's permission to marry his daughter
might have been a fun scene which is why
it was not included in this movie Kim
Basinger is pissed off about something
which proves my theory
when Kim Basinger is pissed about
something that means a whole other movie
needs to get me to resolve it you can
ask the producers of boxing Elena you
don't care about Christian he'll see
that I'll make sure of it you not the
actress but the movie for introducing
then ignoring this character only to
bring her back here at the end as some
kind of sequel teaser Oscar on oscar
violence in this movie i don't know
whose room this is but someone forgot to
tell them they accidentally hung up a
Chronicles of Riddick poster in here the
fact that this room looks exactly like
the one where Heather Ma Toronto who got
killed in hostel two shouldn't worry you
at all marriage proposal number two wins
and yes but so did the first one so
cigarette smoking man here is supposed
to get me feeling all scary and ominous
about the final chapter in reality I'm
just wondering why he needs to relook at
this picture for revenge boner
inspiration here in the dark
and thank God this movie is over
why is it so hot in here I'm the
boyfriend I'm the boss fight' robo-dog
Stratus I'm I apologized that Christian
was so cart with you if I'm Curt with
you was because time is a factor I want
you back I'm the boss here the Blues a
call-in toss salad